one photo sesh is from the world trade
institute at the university of bern in
switzerland which gives us a nice
neutral look at this from outside of
germany it explained to us first of all
where the resistance is coming from here
in germany well i would see three
conditions which i think are important
to mention first of all i think people
are afraid of leaving the status quo the
balance seems to be okay for them they
don't want change one life change second
I think it's important also to note that
over the years cable ization has also
produced some losers and those losers
are in the middle class there are more
studies that show that in OECD countries
the middle class some of them are not
profiting as much from globalization and
other segments of the society is it the
middle class though if I can jump in
there that's loudest the loudest critic
it it is the middle class is
increasingly louder which i am
particularly when we don't look at the
US for instance the middle class is
having a loud voice on this and in the
third and the third point is basically
there is an anti-establishment movement
going on as well everything that comes
from Brussels from bullying this seemed
very critical okay let's look at it from
the other side the the groups that are
behind this resistance the consumer
groups environmental bodies the joining
together and are extremely loud yes and
I think that is also very typical or
maybe it's not so typical for the rest
of the world but Germany has a very
strong civil society organization so
this anti-globalization movement is
already quite old they are able to
mobilize they have lots of funds
actually and they have great marketing
and tactics so where they get where are
they getting all those funds from I
think mostly individuals who I've
described to are not happy of the
current situation and who will be
funding this type of activities so
that's one thing the other thing I think
we need to mention else is that of
course parties on the right and the left
and are also mobilizing and are using
these spheres that develop and make
politics and more and more it's the
parties on the right from what I
understand here in Germany the AFT the
National Front in France
even as far away as the United States
and mr. Trump right right we see it but
we also see it on the left think about
the link in Germany and they also have
been for some time critics and and will
continue to be critics of these types of
in particular trade agreements maybe not
so much Sita with Canada but if you
think about tea tip with the u.s. I mean
there's also then some anti us feelings
that might play a role here is mr.
Trump's opposition to globalization the
same opposition that we're experiencing
here in Europe you see similar reactions
now of course I think the US
presidential campaign is a specific
context in which that happens you see
not just nor Trump voicing concerns on
trade agreements such as TPP the
trans-pacific partnership where the US
has been negotiating with Pacific
partners but also Hillary Clinton has
changed her view on aunty tip on TPP
sorry so there's a lot of wind on the
political side as well we'll get back to
the deals themselves in a moment mr.
ELLs each first let's run through some
of the biggest trade deals for you the
European Union currently has over 40
economic and trade agreements with
countries all over the world those who
favor more treaties say they increase
prosperity for all by simplifying trade
lowering tariffs and increasing exports
entire regions are creating free trade
bloc's like NAFTA made up of the US
Canada and Mexico in South America many
countries have signed on to the Mercosur
trade alliance ossian has brought
together countries in Southeast Asia and
gaff de aims to stimulate trade in the
pan Arab region
the new round of agreements encompass
a--'s even larger areas if the TPP goes
into force it'll include 12 Pacific Rim
nations and affect a third of all global
trade Sita aims to reduce trade barriers
between Canada and the European Union
and T tip is seeking to do the same
between the u.s. and the EU but those
last two proposed agreements have been
heavily criticized because they would
regulate not only trade but also areas
like environmental protection human
rights labor laws security and data
protection critics say the agreements
will lower standards ok so these
agreements go a lot further it's not
just geographically the the bigger area
that they're encompassing but rather
more of our lives more aspects of our
lives is that good or bad well first of
all I think the question really is to
what degree the impact on our lives so I
think what we see is a natural evolution
of these treaties away from tariffs to
what's called non-tariff barriers so
national measures basically that impact
on on trade and investment what we see
basically is that there are increased
efforts to regulate those areas to
increase regulation in particular
between agencies that they increase
their interaction and create new
standards may be a long term but
currently I don't really see a problem
for those who fear the lowering of
standards but what does trade have to do
with human rights environmental
standards well I think this is also
historically we have to see this
historically that in particularly
north-south agreements between developed
and developing countries more and more
of these non trade issues are being
taken up we've seen security issues you
seen democracy environment labor
standards but these are lesson let's say
Seeta aur inti tip these are issues that
are regulated in or south um would you
say that at the moment this is all
playing into politicians hands and that
what we could see as a result is the
voters who were voting
these politicians from the left or right
it could be voting for policies that
further impoverish them does not be a
bit of a paradox right i think this
agreements in particular seat r and t
tip they will on the aggregate to create
wealth and democrat growth in but in
countries like germany but it's hard to
make this point for a politician right
and so I think Germany is in a constant
election cycle and we've seen that in
particularly the Social Democratic Party
has you know an internal division and
this plays out and therefore we see a
division of the government and and it's
this is why I think we see we see more
and more resistance to these agreements
ok mr. as a thank you very much for
coming in today I'm pulling about this
story for us